OK, super cool. Alright,
um, welcome to privacy preserving AI primitives,
uh, building blocks for regulated industry.
Uh, this is ARC 328,
and we're super happy to have you here.
My name is Ruben Mertz. I'm a principal
solutions architect, um, at EDBs, and
I'm here with my colleague Jenny Bean.
Hi y'all, my name is JD Bean.
I'm a principal architect in the AWS,
uh, Compute and ML services
organization. I have the privilege of, uh,
being embedded pretty deeply with our engineering and
product teams, working on a wide range
of services to help enable our customers
to overcome their security, compliance,
and privacy challenges.
Thank you. All right, so thanks
for being here. Um, so I've been working in
regulated industries for, for many years now,
and with AI fundamental need
for data
and growing regulation,
protecting that data is more critical than ever.
Uh, Both JD and I work with
customers like you, regulated customers, exactly
on that topic to help you
adopt and leverage the cloud. And today we want to
tell you about our experience doing exactly
this. We want to give you
essential building blocks for you to protect
this data with confidence.
And so by the end of this talk, we
want you to understand what these building blocks
are and how you can get started.
Now, this is a level 300
session, and we're assuming that you're
familiar with some of
Aba's core services across compute,
database, and storage.
Uh, you also know uh key management services,
encryption address and in transit. Now,
if you don't feel comfortable with this, don't worry,
we'll get you covered.
Uh, we'll go through the basics.
And the most important is that you're
building systems.
So today we cover the following.
We want to double down on the urgency of
data privacy
in today's landscape,
and we'll establish our mental model
for for AI and machine learning
for this talk, as well as the reference scenario
that we are going to use.
Then we'll dive into the building
blocks,
and we'll close with Outlook
and the next steps. So let's get started.
Quick show of hands,
who today here is working in one
of these regulated industries?
All right. Me too.
So you're you're familiar
with the growing regulation, right?
Today, if you're handling regulated
workloads, you have to account
for cybersecurity,
data protection,
business continuity,
and more recently,
AI system regulation.
Now AI systems regulation
is a
fast evolving and complex landscape
to navigate.
It's also super broad.
It extends beyond cybersecurity
into many topics that would each
benefit from a full session.
Now today we want to address
data privacy and data protection.
That's because these topics have emerged
as a central focus. We see convergence
across industries
with data protection, data privacy, cybersecurity,
merging into unified compliance requirements
towards three core capabilities,
essentially visibility.
Secure access and control over your data.
Now
when you handle regulated
data,
assurance is mandatory.
You have governance frameworks and
accountability mechanisms
that require you to have verifiable
evidence
that your data controls
work as intended, and at AWS
what we want.
is to give you the tool and compliance
certifications so that
you have the delivery assurance
so that
you can meet
your compliance requirements and at the same
time benefit from the agility
and innovation of the cloud.
So the slide behind me, the picture is the
well-known shared responsibility model.
We take care of security of the cloud and you
take care of the security in the cloud.
And
that is one, I mean for for this presentation,
we have two tenets. The first one
is we want
to give you building blocks
that provide you assurance,
controls with assurance,
and
building blocks that provide you with verifiable evidence.
So how are we doing this on our side of the
shared responsibility model? Well,
We provide you with contractual commitments,
for example, customer agreement and data processing
addendum. We have more than 140
security certifications and compliance statements,
and we have third party audits.
Now on your side of that
of that model.
I'm sure you can find similar statements
for your vendors.
What we see across our
customers, regulated customers, is very often
for AI that you are using
open source frameworks because they provide you
with complete control and visibility
into how your data is being processed.
Um Now another topic,
this is the AIML spectrum.
There's, there's a broad spectrum, right?
Some of you are using
statistical models with just a few thousands,
just a few 1000 parameters, all the
way to foundation models that have billions
of parameters.
Now, not everyone here is using foundation
models. You might also not be using deep
learning, right?
But you're all using data.
And that's our second tenet.
We want the building blocks that we provide you
today to be broadly applicable
in any of these situations.
And That's
our mental model for today
is basically AI and ML
systems have two core processes, training
and inference,
right? So during training, you have your training
data flows through your training processes
with code that you have written
and gives you a model, right, that you know.
Now during inference, you take this model, you take
new data, it flows through the inference process, and
you get an output.
Now the bottom line here is that for a regulated
environment, what we see is that every component
represents potential sensitive data.
Your training data sets, it can be your code
for training, it can be your model wave, it
can be inference prompts or the outputs,
and depending on your regulatory
requirements
or threat model,
each data type might require protections and
appropriate controls.
I also want to call out or
make a link to the well-known generative AI
security scoping matrix.
This matrix maps 5 implementation
patterns from consumer apps, for
example, like Cloud all the way to enterprise solutions
like Amazon Quick Suite,
and as you move from scope 1
to 5,
you gain increasing control over training
and inference model and data.
And basically at scope 1, the provider
has to handle security. At scope 5, you
own it end to end, so all of it.
OK,
um. Now last slide before
we move into the first building block,
we'll consider 3 types of scenarios
for today. The first one is
our scenarios where you're using Amazon EC2
instances.
Directly or maybe with IKS
for training or for inference in that
scenario you maintain control over the compute
layer. The second scenario
shows serverless inference here with
lambda with minimal infrastructure
management. And the third scenario
that you can consider is one where you're using
you leverage managed AI services, for
example, Bedrock for Foundation model inference or Sagemaker
AI for ML workflow.
All of these scenarios, they can leverage various
storage and database solutions
to provide persistent storage.
And so for each scenario we want to discuss
controls with assurance that apply broadly
regardless of your deployment.
So let's move into our very first building
block, which is none other
than encryption.
Alright, um,
so AWSS key Management Service, KMS
is your central encryption control
plane. It handles
authentication, authorization, and
logging.
Now, from an architecture point of view, the most
important decision that you have to take is
how do you store the keys,
and you have options.
Um With native KMS
you have access to a fleet of shared
HS that are PIPS 140-3
Level 3 compliant.
That's the most reasonable option for
most of the use cases.
The second option is using cloud HSM.
It provides dedicated HSM
for regulated scenarios when your regulation
requires it.
The third scenario that you can use is external
key store, where the keys are being
stored on premises at the expense
of possibly additional latency,
as well as a dependency to your
infrastructure.
And finally, you can also decide to import
external key material
so that you have cryptographic proof of origin.
So there's a spectrum again. As you move
up, you have greater control, but this
comes at the expense of possibly
latency and higher operational overhead.
And basically as you move down you have access to a
managed service that gives you the best.
The best performance
and availability
now. You
can I mean,
Um
And what I wanted to say was that the scenario
that you decide to use pretty much
depends on your compliance and security
requirements, right? You can mix and match. You can
use one or multiple scenarios depending on the workload.
Now the most important thing about KMS in
that context is that keys
never leave KMS unencrypted,
and KMS provides four core cryptographic
operations. The one I want to call out here because we're going to
talk about it later in this presentation,
is the generation and export of
data keys.
KMS integrates with more than 100
services.
And for services like Amazon
S3 or DynamoDB, it's using envelope encryption,
and we'll talk about this later. That's a pattern
we're going to use and reuse throughout the
presentation,
and everything is monitored through CloudWatch
and Cloud 3.
Now let's recap encryption
at rest.
At AWS we provide
3 approaches that allow you to balance
control with operational simplicity.
With client-side encryption, you encrypt
your data
before it reaches AWS, and for this,
you can use SDKs or client-specific
services.
The second option is using customer
manage key in Abase.
This gives you control over the key policy.
As well as the entire life cycle
of the key and in particular in regulated
environments you control the rotation.
This can be mandatory depending on your
compliance requirements.
And the last option is
the use of AWS own keys to provide
transparent encryption for many AWS
services,
automatic rotation, and no charges for storage and
users. And again,
the choice pretty much depends on your
compliance requirements, OK?
And you can use a customer managed key to
provide to protect many machine learning assets
with with these keys. It can be
bedrock custom models. It can be
an agent session,
data or model artifacts
in S3.
Now let's recap encryption in transit
again. We have multiple options,
so you can also use client-side encryption.
Now of course, here you have to decrypt the data
before you can process it. The interesting thing
is that you can use the isolation properties of
EC2 instances or lambda in order
to do this.
Um At the
application layer,
we provide you with TLS 1.2,
NO 1.3 with perfect forward
secrecy.
Uh, this is protecting um
services, for example, for Bedrock or Sedgem
AI and all control plane API.
At the VPC layer.
Between compatible instances
you benefit from automatic encryption
that is taken taken care of by the
Nitro system.
And in addition, in regulated context,
we recently released VPC encryption
control that provides centralized
encryption visibility and enforcement
for all traffic within and across
the VPC.
And again, this is useful
in regulatory context because that might be a
requirement.
Finally, at the physical layer,
we encrypt all traffic at
region boundaries
over our backbone.
As well as between availability
zones and over peering connection, either with
VPC peering or transit gateway.
So together,
all these layers, they create really defense
in depth protection for all of your AIMI
workloads.
One thing I want to call out is a specific use
case, which is for distributed
AI training.
I want to call out Elastic Fabric Adapter, EFA
very briefly.
EFA delivers always encrypted
high performance networking.
It provides hardware accelerated encryption. It takes
advantage of the natural system again.
With no performance penalty, and basically it
gives you GPU direct RDMA
access and up to 3 or 2 terabits per
second of throughput,
and it's really here to enable distributed
AI training at scale without compromising
security. Now
let's try to put that together on a high level
architecture slide.
So at Tres we really want you to use encryption.
We provide
all these options to protect data
across the cloud and on premises
in both directions.
So for example,
here, TLS is going to safeguard
data flowing both ways, training data
imported from your premises,
or from Adores storage services,
all the way into ADres compute services.
This can be EC2
or Lambda.
And it also controls all
control plane API.
I also want to mention Direct Connect
because it uses Maxse at interconnect point,
and you can use
S2S VPN as well on top if you want
to. Within the VPC, we
talked about the nitro system that provides encryption
for training workloads between compatibility EC2
instances.
And of course each storage services
is using encryption at rest,
using envelope encryption with
KMS managed keys that
you can control.
So essentially you maintain control
through your customer
managed keys while we handle
the actual encryption.
Now I want to talk briefly about
envelope encryption because then I want to talk about
client-side encryption.
So envelope encryption implements a
two-tier cryptographic hierarchy where
AWSKMS manages the
master key, while so-called data
keys that you get through generate
data key handle the actual
encryption operation.
So when you call generate data key,
AWSKMS generates a plain text
data key and an encrypted key. You use the
plain text data key to encrypt your data,
and you throw it away. You discard it immediately.
And you store the encrypted version with the
encrypted data that you have.
For decryption, you do the reverse process.
You call in order to decrypt.
The encryption key and then you can decrypt your
data. And this is a stateless architecture.
You don't need to keep state anywhere because you have the
data, you have, you have the encryption key with the data
and
it allows for the encryption of large
data sets, for instance, that
exceed the 4 kilobyte KMS direct encryption
limit,
and it also enables data key
caching to minimize API calls and latency.
That's super important
for large scale AI training and
model artifacts.
So how do you use that in the context of
client-side encryption?
In the context of AIML workloads, well,
a producer can encrypt
training data sets,
model artifacts or inference payloads
on premises or in the cloud using envelope
encryption. Then
it either persists
that ciphertext to S3 or maybe DynamoDB
or can pass it directly to the consumer.
All of the processing,
either the processing of the data or the
encryption or the decryption data, they can
take place across lambda, across EC2,
across on-premises,
and you can even use nitro Enclave in the case of EC2.
Consumers will then retrieve or receive ciphertext,
decrypt with identity and access management
scope permissions, and process the data. That's
an important point, right?
Because you're using key policies, you can precisely
control who is allowed to decrypt the data.
So training data,
model weights, hyperparameters, gradient
checkpoints, whatever,
they can all remain encrypted throughout the
machine learning life cycle.
Now I said we really want you to use
encryption. So we
provide you here 3 options for
client-side encryption.
The first one is the AOS encryption SDK.
This is a
multi, uh, this is a cross-platform
um SDK.
That enables general purpose cryptographic
operation. I often use it in Python or Rust.
Another option is the AWS database
encryption SDK.
It delivers record level encryption
as well as field level signatures that you can
use for data authenticity.
Um
And the last option is the Amazon S3
encryption client.
What's cool about it is that it can automatically
encrypt and decrypt your objects by
intercepting code to put objects
or get objects, so it's completely transparent.
Each of these solutions,
they implement the same envelope encryption primitives
and they optimize for specific use cases
and data schema.
So, let's look at an example.
This Python example
creates first an encryption SDK
client, that's the encryption client on the
slide. Then moves on
to getting a client. That's
what you need.
And basically create a key ring.
Uh, in the context of the query ring, uh, in
the, in the context of the key ring creation.
You can set encryption context metadata
that can be
these are optional non-secret
key value pair
that provides
additional authenticated data for KMS
encryption operation.
And they are bound to the ciphertext, that's
to, for example, prevent ciphertext substitution
attacks. So you can bind
model version or training job ID to
encrypt the training data sets and model artifacts.
Um The encrypt
operation generates unique data keys
per object, and the
decrypt operation is fairly straightforward.
What I'm not showing here
is the use of, for example, data key
caching
that you can control either via amount of
messages, number of bits encrypted, or
age of the key,
and we provide also other options, for example, hierarchical
key rings that can use branch
keys with Dynamo DB.
Sometimes you can't.
Use the encryption SDK, but
nothing prevents you from combining those
best patterns with open source libraries and.
So if we now revisit again our
examples,
client-side encryption provides you another layer
of encryption. So everything you've learned
on the slide before still applies,
encryption and transit and arrest, but you can use
client-side encryption
for additional assurance.
So in the EC2 example,
you can protect data coming in from on-premises
or from storage services, and
again, the advantage here, or one of the
benefits here is that the KMS
key policy gives you gives you precise
control about who is authorized to do the decryption.
All right,
Um,
so, AWS, um.
So database encryption protects data
broadly to secure data,
to secure training data sets, inference data,
and model artifacts.
And the bottom line is that with customer managed keys
you have control.
Our fundamental security principles
are really about making sure that there is no human interactions
with plain text cryptographic key material
across all our services.
I want to now, I want to briefly
discuss a second
short building block.
Which is tokenization.
Tokenization can complement encryption.
Basically what tokenization allows you to do
is to reduce compliance scope
by simply
removing or replacing sensitive
data from your data set.
In the example here,
we have, for example,
credit card numbers
or an email address, and these are
being replaced by tokens.
Tokens can be randomly or pseudo
randomly generated.
The tokens
or the key value pair, the token as
well as the original mapping, are being stored
in what's called a token vault.
The point here of having a token vote is
that it's also a central point of control
for who has the authorization.
To recover the original mapping
between sensitive data and the actual token.
All right, so let us look at the high-level architecture.
This diagram shows you one
potential implementation,
um, using a server-less approach
with AWS lambda.
So you see here, one lambda function
that takes care of the tokenization
process, right?
And you see another lambda function that is
implementing
the business logic for the actual tokenization
via some cryptographic operation.
You can also see that we're using
the pattern, the client-side encryption pattern, so
on top of encryption address and in transit
we're adding another.
A layer of protection with client-side
encryption using the Edobase
database encryption.
Again,
keep in mind that tokenization will reduce
compliance scope by removing sensitive
data from your system. With that,
we're moving to our 3rd building blocks, and I will let
JD come on stage.
Thanks Reuben. So
we've talked a little bit about encryption in
transit, we've spoken a little bit about
encryption at rest,
and now we move on to
perhaps an area that is a little bit
more on the frontiers, a little bit more
present in the dialogue
of the last say 5
years or so than it was previous to
that, which is the concept of protecting
data
while it is in use.
Before I move forward,
we'll, we'll speak about a few ways of
approaching this problem.
The area that I'm going to focus on is
called confidential computing. Can I
see a quick show of hands about who may have heard
of that concept before?
OK, we have a few,
so I'll define it briefly for you now, which is
we really define confidential computing as
the act of trying to uh
protect sensitive uh data
or code from any external
unauthorized access through the use of special
purpose hardware,
firmware, and associated software.
At AWS, the primary confidential
computing technology we offer
is known as the AWS Nitro System.
Uh, the Abus nitro system is,
uh, really fundamentally the underlying,
uh, technology that powers, uh, every
single virtualized EC2
instance that we have released
since 2018 and on.
Uh, this was the process of many, many years of
development beginning in 2012 and
culminating in the official unveiling
and release to, to the world of
the nitro system in November of 2017
here at RIM.
Uh, it consists of
a collection of special purpose hardware devices
as well as a custom hypervisor
built for AWS
and now 6 generations, uh, we're now
on our 6th generation of custom chips
that powers the system.
What this enables us to offer to our customers
is something that is pretty much
unheard of in the industry.
We offer always on
confidential computing to each and every
user of any EC2 instance that's
based on the nitro system,
i.e., any modern instance released
since 2018 and onwards. This
is free of cost. It's free of
performance impact.
It is simply the default offering
of every single EC-2 instance.
There is no
technical mechanism for anyone at
AWS to access the
contents of a customer's nitro-based
EC-2 instance or
encrypted storage or encrypted transit
traffic moving in and out of
the physical underlying virtualization
server. Customers don't need to change
their code to enable this. It is simply
there and always on, and that's
really the beauty of confidential computing compared
to some of the techniques we'll talk about
later, which is that it enables you to, to,
um, isolate sensitive data
without substantially modifying your
general purpose
uh code.
So
I'm not gonna get too into exactly how
we manage this. It's a great story. Uh, I
I've made a habit of telling it on quite a few stages,
uh, but we've gone to great lengths to provide assurance
for our customers about this claim.
One of the first things we did was to publish a deep dive
white paper that provides a uh um
an overview, uh, and kind of
deep understanding of how the different components
of the nitro system work together to create this
outcome. We've also provided a third
party validation from an outside security
firm, the NCC Group,
which came in and affirmed our security
claims about zero operator access.
Lastly,
we provided a very clear and simple
statement in our service terms, Section 96,
which has been updated to reflect a commitment to each
and every AWS customer about
this zero operator access
posture.
Now it's important to note in this context
that the protection of EC2 instances covers
not only the CPU
resources or the VCPU of a of a customer's
instance or the memory.
That they use but also the contents of
any associated accelerator devices
whether that's uh AWS's ranium chips
or uh Nvidium Qualcomm,
uh AMB or Intel accelerators
we've listed some uh of the accelerators
uh and and uh and GPU
powered instances here that this covers but of
course this also applies to some of the instances that we've
released just this week
here uh at RIM.
Now
as we began to interact more and more with our customers
and to tell them about this uh
this this property that we had baked into
the nitro system,
we heard more from our customers about them asking
whether or not they
could be enabled to build systems that similarly
excluded any possibility
of external unauthorized access
at a deep and technical level.
Now I wanna be clear here.
Not every workload
requires this type of mechanism.
Furthermore, not every regulated workload
That said, there are, uh, we, we do speak
regularly with customers who are looking
for these capabilities and who feel that they will
help them to achieve
their, their compliance
requirements, their security requirements,
or even just to help them to build
trust with prospective customers.
So ultimately
when we
speak with our customers about how they can design a system
like this, the first questions we ask them are
what are you looking to protect, i.e.,
what is the sensitive confidential data,
and who are you looking to protect that from.
If
Uh, the folks that you were trying to protect that from
are AWS operators.
There is no need to change the way you
design your code running in EC-2, uh,
in a nitro-based EC-2 instance, right? As
I mentioned earlier,
you already have that protection on by default.
Now, if what you're concerned about is something like
perhaps like your own operators or administrators
or, uh, supply chain issues,
uh, that's where we have a couple of, uh,
other technologies I wanna share with you today.
So the, the first offering that we, we released
to our customers was called AWS Nitro
Enclaves.
What this enables you to do is to take an EC2
instance
that would otherwise have have contained, you know, potentially,
uh, administrative access,
uh,
large kind of stacks of third
party applications and
code. That would previously have
had to bring in data that was either
encrypted at rest or in transit and then decrypt
it for processing in plain text.
You can actually take that instance now and divide
it into two
strongly isolated compute domains.
Um, technically these are basically
two pure VMs that operate
within what is logically your EC2 instance.
And the second virtual machine we call a nitro
enclave. Now nitro enclave in many
respects is like another EC2 instance
running alongside your EC2 instance, but
it has a few differences.
It doesn't have, uh, local storage,
doesn't have, uh, a TCIP-based
IP networking connection.
By default, there's no SSH
or remote interactive access into the nitro
enclave,
and all of this creates a constrained,
uh, and lowered surface area of
attack.
Critically, it's also very useful that a nitro enclave
can be launched using a file
that can be hashed up to ultimately
represent a single cryptographic
value that contains the entire
execution context, i.e.,
everything inside the enclave that can
run, that can do anything, is
ultimately represented and traceable back to
this hash value.
Keep that in mind as we'll return to it in just a few slides.
So as we spoke more and more with our customers
who were really enjoying nitro enclaves, what we found was
that
customers wanted to take their own EC2
instance. They didn't really feel the need to divide
into two different parts, but what they wanted
to do was make their own EC2 instance
isolated and hardened in a way that was very similar
to a nitro enclave.
So we recently, just a few months ago, released
a new offering to help our customers
apply a zero operator access configuration
to their own EC-2 instance.
What this ultimately looks like is provide
uh kind of
uh taking a copy of Amazon Linux,
uh, a few recipes that AWS provides,
as well as the trusted and uh trusted
code and apps provided by the customer,
combining them together using a
tool called uh Kiwi Next Generation
and ultimately, uh, creating.
An AMI or AMIN, a machine image
for an EC2 instance that
doesn't contain things like SSH
or serial console access,
uh, that that has a read-only file system
to create an immutable image
that can boot up and similarly
be captured
uh from beginning to end
with a single cryptographic hash.
Now I mentioned
I would speak more about this idea of a cryptographic
hash
in a second.
And here we are.
So, uh, we now have
these two capabilities, uh, both
the nitro TPM, which powers,
uh, this attestable AMI flow I
mentioned earlier, and nitro enclaves
that are both able
to provide
a cryptographic attestation.
Of the code that runs inside them
to a third party system, so what they're able to do is
to obtain a document
from the nitro hypervisor
that uh that attests to the
specific measurements of those
environments so that external systems
can validate.
That the code running inside is in
fact the code that is authorized
to uh
for for various interactions.
Now, a particularly useful flow
there is our interaction with those two cryptographic
attestation mechanisms, and AWSKMS.
So what we do with Nitro TPM or nitro
enclaves is to take a measurement, generate
that attestation document,
sign it with a nitro hypervisor,
and allow these environments to pass a
request to AWS KMS
to say, for example, decrypt
a secret value or
uh or cryptographic credential.
Uh, the AWS KMS can then
validate the attestation document,
uh, and make an authorization decision
based upon the contents of it before either
choosing to deny the request
or returning back the secret value
to the, uh, the calling
trusted execution environment.
Now
this is a bit uh a a
a bit of a noisy screen,
uh, but I've I've highlighted two particular
values here in blue and purple.
So one is uh PCR 4 in a
nitro TPM attestation document.
This value corresponds to the to this
measurement I was talking about earlier, right? This is
basically a chained, uh, value.
Uh, that corresponds to the entire
boot context of
this EC2 instance. So it includes the
kernel,
the boot code,
uh, and also the root file system.
So this basically measures the entire, uh,
instance. It basically is at a very, very low,
like from a technical level, a cryptographic
version of execution identity.
PCR 7.
Is something somewhat different.
It's actually chained to the uh UEFI
secure boot policy of the
instance. Now there's a lot of details
in there that probably aren't worth going into here,
so I'm gonna take a step back and basically tell you how you can
think of that value.
It effectively corresponds
to the ability to say
has this instance been signed
or has this, uh, this set of code been signed
by a particular, uh, cryptographic
token. So generally, right, what this looks
like is effectively that you have a CICD
pipeline
and you're able to sign things that come out of that
pipeline and bless them as being appropriate
to handle sensitive data.
Um, usually the, the the
bar for that sensitive data, uh,
access is going to be something like zero
operator access.
Now, you take one of these two measurements,
or perhaps both, uh, of course PCR
4 is a very, very specific measurement
and is, uh, you know, perhaps a bit brittle, whereas
PCR 7 is a little bit more scalable but
slightly lower assurance,
and you could take these values
and actually plug them in directly to the KMS
key policy that you set in KMS,
right? So here you have, um, a principal
being allowed to decrypt a value
and you see under the conditions section.
That we're looking for particular values
in the recipient attestation nitro
TP TPM PCR
uh insert number here, so 4
or 7.
And what we do here is include the two values
from our attestation document.
OK. We've laid a little
bit of groundwork. What does that actually look like? How
can I use that to achieve a valuable
outcome? So here's
a very, very simple architectural diagram
um of what this looks like.
You have, for example, an end user device
that will encrypt data using an AWS
KMS key
that only
permits decryption of that data
when the request comes along with an attestation
document
bearing a trusted measurement PCR
value. So the encrypted user data
is then sent
into a nitro-based EC-2 instance
that has full access to one of these powerful
accelerators,
as I mentioned at the outset of
my talk today,
right, uh, we already know that AWS
operators do not have access to
this EC2 instance.
We also know because of the measurements and
because of the pre-validation that we performed.
That also no operators or staff
from the underlying uh from the customer that operates
the EC-2 instance can also
access the contents of that sensitive data
or
modify the uh the
the the systems that run inside the EC2
instance. So once this data comes in,
a call is made to KMS. KMS then
validates the attestation document,
decrypts the data, sends it back using
TLS.
And an inference request is able to be
performed. So
let's take a look at ways in which these types
of technologies as base primitives
can be integrated into some of the uh
workflows that we've spoken about so far
so I actually wanna go back to tokenization
which Ruben was speaking about briefly
so here.
One of the things about tokenization is of course that at
some point the sensitive data needs
to be tokenized. It needs to be transformed,
and what better type of environment to
handle that sensitive data and perform
that sensitive tokenization
process than.
A nitro enclave or
an attestable EC2 instance.
Right there you have zero operator access, you have
a strong isolation boundary, and
inside you can then safely handle this sensitive
data and transform it into
less sensitive data.
Uh, thanks to attestation, you can also
be confident that the attestation service
you are providing that sensitive data to,
uh, is, uh, the attested service, is
in fact the an appropriate tokenization
system, and then it will handle it
as its code has instructed it to.
Now here's a bit of a more complex
view uh that is directly
tied with uh an
inference uh request.
So in this case this could be an agent executing
a local model or
even just a, you know, a a broader direct
more simple kind of prompt
response inference flow,
but you have basically a client device
that encrypts the prompt data using a KMS
key that has been similarly configured
to only allow decryption by a trusted environment.
That data is then sent in, encrypted
client side,
um,
through to an EC2 instance, which
has the ability,
thanks to cryptographic attestation, to prove that it is
a trusted environment to KMS.
To then decrypt the prompt, to
perform an inference uh function and
potentially additional processing on it,
and then to return uh to re-encrypt
that data and return it back to the client,
all without any system.
Uh That has any
potential for unauthorized access ever
having been able to access that customer data
in plain text.
Now, similarly, you could perform uh uh
something relatively relatively equivalent
with a nitro enclave. The only difference
is nitro enclaves do not have direct
access to accelerator hardware. So
typically here you'd be thinking about a smaller model
that would still operate performantly
with CPU based inference.
Um, that said, because of the nitro enclave's ability
to run as effectively a sidecar to another
compute environment.
It opens the possibility for more distributed
uh inference uh workloads and opportunities there.
And with that said, I'm gonna hand things back to Ruben
to close things out.
Thank you. Thank
you. We're now going to move
on to building blocks that are more on
your side of the shared responsibility model.
The first one we want to talk about is federated
learning.
It addresses cases where
your data might be constrained to specific
boundaries. This can be because of regulatory
constraints,
organizational boundaries, or security boundaries.
In this context,
further learning in, inverts the centralized
training model.
You have nodes that collaboratively
work together across across
a distributed data set,
and each node keeps data locally.
And only shares model updates
with a centralized aggregation server.
So raw data never leaves the
node, essentially the boundary.
We can highlight two options for production
for production implementations.
One of them is the flow is the open source
flower framework,
which provides flexibility with support, for example,
for Pytorch or Tensorflow
and provides enterprise scale deployment.
And the other one is Nvidia Flair that delivers
GPU support.
And on AWS you can deploy federated learning
via via SageMaker containers
on EC2, on EKS, on ECS, or
even some other options.
This diagram highlights ferreted
learning on EWS with security and
force at multiple layers, so we keep the
same principles of having multiple layers
of security.
So the central orchestrator distributes the
global model. To nodes
on AWS or external premises,
the attestable AI here, for example, provides
cryptographic proof that instances
run trusted software, and now
each node
trains locally on private data and returns
only encrypted model parameters,
never raw data,
and the aggregator combines
updates using secure aggregation protocols.
So security operates at multiple levels.
You have the Nitro TPM to help for
cryptographic attestation.
You have client-side encryption to
provide additional protection for encryption.
You have identity and access management to control
who can, for example, proceed to decryption
operation or communicate with the central
aggregation server,
and you can use,
for example, IM
anywhere to make sure that
only authorized nodes can participate in
the protocol.
To dive deeper, you can find
here selected articles from the
ERs and Amazon science blogs.
The The second building
block that we want to talk about is
one that addresses a fundamental challenge
when tied to privacy protection.
Um, We want to talk about
differential privacy, or I will use
the word DP in short, and
it addresses the challenge that it addresses is
the erosion
of privacy through repeated queries
or analysis or the availability of side
information, and I think the best is to give you an example.
So let's consider queries on the
student earnings data sets,
and our study run 2 queries
across a semester, one at the beginning of the semester
and the second one at the end of the semester.
And the first query is returns that
out of 3,005 students,
earn over 400.
The second query
returns later in time that out of 3,0004
students, 201 earn over
400 in the second.
This one student difference can prove critical
because it provides precise information about
a specific individual.
And now let's say that someone has
access to side information.
They know that they know the specific
student who left the school during the semester.
They are able to recover the identity
of that student.
They can identify the individual.
So differential privacy is a
mathematical framework to provide mathematical
guarantees on protecting
individual data.
The fundamental intuition
is that DP
injects carefully calibrated
statistical noise into either calibration
or queries.
And that noise has to be tuned
in order to obscure specific data
points, but at the same time to make sure
that the model remains reasonably accurate.
And in practice you have to involve two considerations.
One of them is you have to manage the so-called privacy
budget. So you need to make sure
there's a parameter that's called epsilon that can be used
for that, that quantifies how much additional.
How much privacy
you lose at every query and the other parameter
is called delta.
It's to prevent catastrophic privacy failure
where the model suddenly breaks down and reveals
all private information, and there are trade-offs
here that essentially balance accuracy
along with how much you can protect
individual information and computational
complexity. So,
if you want to implement differential privacy
into your algorithm, there are plenty of
open source frameworks
that exist.
It really depends on your use cases,
and at AWS we provide
one option
that we'll discuss afterwards with AWS Cleanroom.
Um Now I want to finish
giving you the intuition
of of how DP works.
So now let's say that the analysts were using
a DP-based system that
is adding control randomness.
Now the first query would simply return
a noisy count of 204 students
that earn over 400, and the second
query would return a noisy count
of 199 that
returned over 40k.
And that randomness is what prevents
identifying a specific individual.
Differential privacy is a tool
that adds formal privacy guarantee
that remains robust, and it's one complementary
approach. You can, for example,
often use it with ferreted learning in
order to prevent privacy erosion
across many turns.
Now, um.
Implementing different differential privacy
is complex. You have to manage privacy
budget. You have to manage, you have to tune the
parameters.
You have to know how
to take care of it over multiple queries,
and AWS Cleanroom is a service
for secure
multi-party data collaborations, and
it, it essentially implements managed
differential privacy control. So in this
context you can have a so-called
clean room operator
that can set the total privacy budget.
And for example, here
we have
3 queries that consume a certain
amount of that budget, and the 4th query.
Goes over the budget and in that case
the query is basically prevented,
which prevents the leaking
of individual information.
Um,
Again, if you want to dive deeper, we
really encourage you to explore selected
articles from our Amazon science colleagues.
You can find one early reference that dates back
to 2008. So this is something we've been working
on for a long time.
The last building block that
I want to tell you about is my favorite one.
So what if you never had
to disclose data?
This is cryptographic computing. With cryptographic
computing, you can perform computation
on encrypted data
without ever decrypting it.
And this comprises multiple
forms with different trade-offs.
So for example, with open source
frameworks such as Xama or
Open, you
can perform computation on arbitrary
functions. Now this comes with the
trade-off at the expense of performance.
On AWS we provide two
options
for production deployment.
One of them is integrated into Cleanroom.
I'll tell you about it afterwards.
And the other one is integrated into the
AWS database encryption SDK.
It provides encrypted search.
So again, if we come back to our tokenization
example, that's a pretty cool
application because now let's say that you have to
figure out
a specific mapping between an
original token and its encrypted mapping.
Without encrypted search, you have to go through all of the
mapping and encrypt each one of them.
Thanks to encrypted search, you can do that
search without ever decrypting
the data. In
the context of clean rooms,
the use case that it addresses are
regulatory scenarios where you cannot
put the data,
the data has to remain encrypted
on the cloud.
One thing to always be aware with cryptographic
computing, it comes with trade-off. In the context
of Cleanroom. These trade-offs are the following. One
of them is that the participants must
agree on a shared secret key.
Um The
other one
is that
it restricts the use of cryptographic
encryption with clean rooms reduces
the amount, reduces the type of
operations that you can do.
On your collaboration room, so you can't use all
the operations that you could use without cryptographic
computing.
And the third, um, the 3rd aspect that
you have to pay attention to is uh overhead
in terms of storage.
Now I want to talk,
I want to talk about fully homomorphic encryption.
Which enables computing arbitrary
functions on encrypted data without
ever decrypting them, and
the example that you show here
is a high level example to give you the intuition.
Essentially you have a plain text X that is
encrypted.
And then
the function F,
which is a mapping of the computation that you
want to do
but that can work over encrypted function, operates
directly on the ciphertext to produce an encrypted
result that can then be decrypted.
If you're familiar with these type of approaches,
you might have heard that they've been traditionally
super computationally expensive.
Now in the recent years, there has been a lot of progress,
either in terms of accelerated acceleration
options by using ASIC or GPU
which you find on the cloud,
or
by finding specific
specific optimization for use cases.
And today, the bottom line
is that you can apply this type of techniques
for AI workloads with
acceptable trade-offs.
One of the things that I find the most impressive is
that today modern approaches can even
give you a compiler that can automatically
take the small FOfix and transform
it into a capital FOIX,
so it makes the usability
much, much, much better than something
like 10 years ago.
So let me show you that in action.
I'm here giving you an example with Open
FHE. It's one of the open source libraries that
you can use. It has Python bindings which
make it very approachable
if you want to get started.
That example shows you vector multiplication.
And so what you see is that in step one
we have to set up a cryptographic context and we
have to select a specific scheme.
In step two,
we have to generate encryption keys.
In step 3, we encrypt, no
surprise, and
The most important step is step
4, where we do operation on encrypted
data. Here in that specific scenario,
we're doing,
we're doing a vector multiplication,
and step 5 is the decryption.
And this is something that you can run on your own
laptop or machine if you want.
Now let me give you,
if you can do this, that means that you
can do machine learning. You can, for example, apply it
for inference.
Let me here show you another example
that has been adapted from an open source repository.
This is this is a linear support
vector machine in France.
The structure is very much the same.
The only difference are the operations that we're
using, OK?
And for example, in that example, we're
taking a trade-off
between performance and data protection.
So what here in that example remains
encrypted
are the values are the inference values, but
the model weights remain in plain text. But
you don't have to do that, right? There's a trade-off that you can
choose. That
example, if you run it on a
reasonably sized
CPU machines,
runs in under a few
in under tens of milliseconds
and provides close to 95%
accuracy compared to a plain text approach.
So that means that you can actually
Deploy these approaches in the clouds
on a lambda function in a surveillance approach.
That last high level architecture
shows you 3 different implementation
deployments
that very much depend
on your model type
and on the performance requirement that you have.
This is a client-server architecture
where the client is responsible for
setting up a public-private key
and to handle
a communication protocol with a model serving
API. So,
For a lightweight FHE model,
you can use the synchronous lambda path,
that's the one on the top
that basically
processes requests directly in the lambda function
and returns the result.
If you have more computationally
intensive models, for example, you're using
this type of techniques on a reasonably sized,
reasonably sized neural networks,
you can either use a surveillance approach with GPUs,
for example, with ECS.
Or you can you can use asynchronous
processing
where you're going to first put the result into a queue, it
gets acted on later,
and you recover the result later.
And the third option,
um, well, actually the 3rd, that was the 3rd option that
I described where you don't have GPU support.
You also need an S3 bucket
because you need to be able to store what's called an evaluation
key, which is specific cryptographic
material that you use in those cases, and that's generally
too large in order to be passed
directly via API calls.
And what we really want to show you here
with this slide is that there's a perfect
match between the clouds
and cryptographic computing, right,
because you have access to surveillance resources
and to GPUs and your data
can remain encrypted at all times.
Again, this was our last building block, and
that's one with great potential, and we'd love
to hear how we
can help you
here. And to dive deeper, here is
another selection of resources and articles
from our Amazon science colleagues.
All right, let's wrap up.
We've shown you multiple building blocks, and our
key message here is privacy in depth.
You can use them together. You can combine
them to meet your specific compliance
and protection requirement. There is not a
one size fits all, right?
It's all about visibility,
secure access, and control over
data. At the end of the day, what
we want you is to be able to meet.
Your compliance requirements and to benefit
from the agility and innovation
benefits of the cloud.
The other thing that we really want to call out
here is that data
protection and privacy
is something fundamental at AWS,
and many of these naming blocks, they are used
under the hood with managed
AWS services.
For example, with Amazon Bedrock,
we ensure that your data is never shared with foundation
model providers,
prompt data is not stored.
All API calls remain within your AWS
regions. We're using encryption
in transit and encryption at rest with
customer managed keys.
CloudWatch and Coltrail, they provide
monitoring and auditability
backed by over 20 compliance standards, and
the same set of principles and
approaches
are being applied to Sagemaker AI.
Um,
finally. This presentation
is about building blocks with assurance.
OK? At AWS,
uh, security,
data protection,
and privacy are foundational to
everything that we do and build.
And as for you, builder of regulated industries,
I said that several times.
We really want you to use encryption
and have control of your keys backed
by KMS.
Encryption is easy on AWS, so
just use it.
The nitro system is always is
always on. It provides strong physical
and logical isolation
together with attestation capabilities,
and that gives you control over how
your data can be processed.
And finally,
on your side of the shared responsibility model, take
advantage of furthered learning, differential
privacy, cryptographic computing.
They are here today. You can use them, right?
And again, we'd love to hear
how we can help you there
and how to deploy them in production.
These building blocks give you the
confidence and assurance to innovate while
you comply
with an evolving regulatory landscape.
Thank you very much for listening, and we'll be
available to take your questions.
Just after outside this room.